FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi and
welcome to episode number
62 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing
great, very, very, very happy
about having the opportunity
to interview someone
about Cloud Spanner.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
not only someone,
but the product manager
of Cloud Spanner.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah it's going
to be really, really cool,
super looking forward
to that because Spanner
is really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
In a minute we will
be joined by Deepti Srivastava.
She's the product manager
for Cloud Spanner.
And after that, we
will have a question
of the week that comes directly
from the amazing Jessie
Frazelle.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
know, which is related
to how to run mail
servers on the Cloud,
specifically on Google
Cloud Platform, obviously.
MARK MANDEL: Obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, but before that,
we have our cool things
of the week as usual.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so the
first cool thing of the week
comes from our boss,
really, Greg Wilson,
the fantastic Greg's
ramblings on Twitter,
which is a picture of each
Google Cloud product described
in four words or less.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
when he says picture,
I think he means a screen shot.
There's not an actual
picture of the products.
But it is basically like,
what is Cloud Dataproc?
Well, it's managed
Spark and Hadoop.
OK.
So--
MARK MANDEL: What
is Cloud logging?
It is centralized logging.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that is.
But some of them are very,
very useful, like some of them
are obvious, like Speech API.
It converts speech
to text, cool.
But when you're
reading something
that you might not know
that much what it is,
like for instance, I don't
know, like, what is, let me see,
Cloud Shell?
Shell is kind of a
weird thing to say.
It's actually a
browser-based terminal CLI.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
or a Cloud Bigtable
is HBase compatible NoSQL.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
don't know, I really like it.
I think it's a very useful
cheat sheet to have around,
especially if you're
trying to explain to people
what Google Cloud has.
This is a very good
thing to share easily.
We have a screen
shot, but also we
have a spreadsheet
on Google Docs
that you can go and copy,
paste, and modify as you wish.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
For the other cool
thing of the week,
I thought it was a particularly
nice one on the big data side.
We currently are having a
challenge with a Google Cloud
and YouTube to predict YouTube
video tags for a chance
to win up to 30k.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So in partnership
with YouTube, Google Research,
and Kaggle, Google Cloud
platform, basically
have set up this thing where
you have a public data set with,
I believe it's about
8 million video tags--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So close,
7 million video URLs,
which is around 450,000 hours
of video, and 3.2 billion,
with a B, audio visual features.
That's a big number.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a big number.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That is actually
a big number, yes, OK.
Why'd they call it 8M?
OK, interesting,
but that's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They
call it 8M because they
have 7 million YouTube videos.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
that makes sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Interesting, yeah, whatever.
MARK MANDEL: So basically
using Cloud Machine Learning,
TensorFlow, or basically any of
your favorite machine learning
frameworks, the challenge
is to develop classification
algorithms so you can,
basically, accurately
assign labels to the
videos that are playing.
So you can use those videos
that are available in that data
set to build your own
classification systems
and hopefully win like 30k.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I don't think I will have
time to get to do it,
but you can use
Google Cloud Machine
learning and TensorFlow, or
whatever you feel like using.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So if
you have any cool software
that you think could do better
than everything else, go,
go for it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and it's
worth noting, too, right--
so specifically, we'll
link to the page,
but you can sign up for,
basically, a Google Cloud
Platform trial account if
you want to try it out.
And there is a process
there if you end up
using more than $300 that
you get with free trial,
and you're working on this,
and you want some more credits,
there is a form there that
you can apply for as well
to get some extra credits
so you can keep working
on what you're working on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I guess it's time
to go chat with Deepti
about Cloud Spanner.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm very, very happy
to welcome today to the podcast
to the Cloud Spanner product
manager, Deepti Srivastava.
How are you doing?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Very good, thank you.
That was very good
pronunciation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you, I've been practicing.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Good job.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we are very
excited about having you today,
especially because,
you know, it's
like, Cloud Spanner was launched
a couple days ago, really.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
there's so many people
that have so many
questions about Cloud
Spanner, and the difference
between Cloud Spanner
and Spanner, and
what does it do,
and the CAP theorem, with did
we break it, all that stuff.
But before we get into
all of those details,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself
and what you do at Google?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
So my name is Deepti Srivastava.
You did a great job
with that, by the way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: I
am the product manager
for Cloud Spanner.
I've been at Google for
a little over four years.
And I was actually
responsible for launching
the internal Spanner
service as well.
So I have a long
history with Spanner
that I'm very excited
to share today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, so
let's get stuck in.
So from a high level,
what is Cloud Spanner?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
So Cloud Spanner,
which we launched this week,
very exciting for all of us
in Spanner and as well as
in general Google Cloud,
we weren't expected
to have that product,
is a fully managed, horizontally
scalable, relational database
service that can have
ACID transaction and SQL
semantics without
giving up performance
and high availability.
So that was a lot of words.
Let's unpack.
Basically what Spanner,
or Cloud Spanner does,
is it gives you the
best of both worlds.
So it gives you the best
of traditional, relational
databases as well as
traditional, non-relational
or NoSQL databases.
So what that means is we
have schemas, DDL statements,
strong typing, SQL querying,
and much more in that category.
But we also have
horizontal charting
that can span multiple
availability zones and multiple
regions across the globe.
And we can do all of
this without compromising
on performance or
high availability.
And to top it all,
we've offered this
as a fully managed
service, so you
don't have to worry
about managing
this database yourself.
It's completely managed
on the Cloud Platform
with our SRE team and
the entire infrastructure
that Google runs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, kind of like
what we did with Bigtable
but for relational.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So you mentioned that
you were responsible
for the internal
launch of Spanner
and also for Cloud Spanner,
which is the external service.
Could you talk a little
bit about differences
between those two, a little
bit of the history of how
this happened?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
So let me tackle the
first thing first.
So Cloud Spanner is basically
the internal spanner service
that we've been running for
multiple years, which has been
developed for even more years.
And it's just a repackaging of
that service as a Google Cloud
Platform service.
So we basically integrated
with the Cloud Platform, things
such as billing, and
providing the APIs
through the various rest
and gRPC methodologies,
et cetera, right?
So it's just the same service.
The underlying infrastructure
is exactly the same.
And it's run by
the same SRE team,
or managed by the same
SRE team that manages
the internal service as well.
There is really no
difference except for the way
you access the service.
MARK MANDEL: So it really sounds
like another example of where
we've taken stuff that
we've built inside Google,
and managed inside Google,
and run inside Google,
and had power, all the stuff
inside Google, and just said,
hey, customers, here's
a thing that you
might want to use as well.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
You know, so I've
been asked this
question from customers
as well, because they're
like, are you just throwing
what you had
internally externally
and just expecting people to
handle whatever you throw out
there?
And that's not what we've done.
We've actually
spent a lot of time
both evaluating
whether Spanner would
be a useful external service
to our Cloud customers,
and then we spent a year or so
in our Early Access Program,
where we had customers sort of
working with us as partners,
evaluating sort of what
the API should look like,
how we should offer it,
what are the features that
need to be there.
So what do our enterprise
customers actually need,
because Spanner itself
has a huge surface area
of features in API.
We didn't make it
complicated and confusing
for the customers.
And there was actually a demand
for something like Spanner.
And then we developed that
as the Cloud Spanner service
and launched it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So going back to the
question about the history.
So when I joined Google,
I was a software engineer.
And I was working
in AdWords' backend,
and everything was
MySQL everywhere.
And it was fun.
And then everyone started
migrating to Spanner.
And for me, it was pretty
crazy because at the same time
that we were
migrating to Spanner,
everybody else was migrating
to non-relational databases.
Why did we create, rather
than moving to Spanner,
or the question would
be, why would you
use Spanner instead of
like Bigtable or something
like that?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: That's
an easy answer, right?
Bigtable is not a
relational database.
It's a wide column store, or
key value store at the end,
at the bottom of it.
It's a NoSQL system.
And spanner is a, essentially,
traditional relational system
with scale.
But to go back to the history--
so basically about
2007-ish or so, Google
was facing the issues
that current enterprise,
or just current
companies face today,
which is they really need
relational transactional
semantics, because that makes
development of applications
easier and it makes reasoning
about things that you really
care about, like your bank
accounts and things like that,
much easier because
you have transactions.
But with the explosion of
data, there is so much data,
and you want so many more
insights from that data,
that a traditional
single box sort
of vertical solution for the
database doesn't actually work.
So you need to go to NoSQL or
something that's scaled out.
And that becomes
really problematic
because if you choose
the NoSQL solution,
then you have to build all
the transactional semantics
and such in the application.
You don't get SQL.
You get something
SQL-like, which
you have to train
your developers when
using this exact esoteric
thing, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
So we were facing
the same challenge.
And so a group of
engineers, like Jeff Dean,
and Sanjay, and Andrew
Fikes, and a whole bunch
of other people
kind of got together
and started to look at
what can we do about this.
And that's where kind of
Spanner came from, right?
So we wanted to have
a transactional system
with relational semantics,
and strong schemas and types,
which also provided
horizontal scalability,
with global presence,
and those qualities,
because that's what Google
applications themselves need,
like AdWords.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And
then many more since then.
And so that's kind of
the history of Spanner.
And as we developed it, we
realized that actually SQL
is really useful as a way
to sort of access this data.
And it's very prevalent.
And it makes the lives of
the developers much easier
to use, like, standard SQL.
And so we built in sort of
a SQL engine into Spanner,
which is what we
offer now today,
which uses what we
call standard SQL,
which is ANSI C 2011
compliant, with extensions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So does that
include things like joins,
or stuff like that,
like fancy Google things
that you can do with SQL?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yes.
It's a query-only, so
select-only SQL interface.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
But yes, it has joins.
You can join across
many tables, any number
of tables in your database.
You can do inner
joins, outer joins.
And you can do indexes.
We have strong secondary
indexes like you
have with any other database.
Those indexes are
called local or global,
depending on whether you use
interleaving or not, which,
again, you can look these
things up on the site.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I watched a talk
not that long ago from someone
that used to work at Google.
I don't know, maybe you
know her because she
used to work in that
team, Neha Narula?
I don't know if you've
ever heard about her,
but she gave a really good talk.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: I have not.
OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: She
gave a really good talk
about serial visibility, and
like the CAP theorem and stuff
like that.
And she talks a lot about,
what is consistency,
and all the
different definitions
of consistency, which is
like, what is consistency?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Do you
mean global consistency
or consistency in general?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is the
consistency we care about?
Because I've heard about
global consistency,
sequential consistency,
and causal consistency.
There's many kinds.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about what is this
thing that people
talk about when they
say consistency related
to Spanner and Cloud Spanner?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So
first of all, consistency
is a whole topic
in and of itself.
And people get very
religious about it.
I don't want to get there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, good.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: But to
put it simply, basically
there are eventual consistent
systems, or eventually
consistent systems,
which basically
means you do an operation
and eventually, we
can't guarantee
when, but eventually
all parts of the system
will see that change.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, Bigtable
would be one of those?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
One of those, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Data store.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Data
store is also one of those.
And then there is a sort
of causal consistencies.
If you are in the path of
something happening, right?
So if you observe one
thing and then observe
another thing as a causal
relationship between those,
if there is a causal
relationship between those two,
then you will see the outcome,
If there isn't, then you
don't see a change reflected.
And then what Spanner has,
or what Cloud Spanner offers,
is strong consistency,
which again,
depending on who you talk to,
has different definitions.
But basically strong
consistency means
that if you commit a change,
and if the system says
it's committed, as in
the system accepts it,
then all parts of the system
see that change instantaneously
or immediately.
There is no concept of I saw
some change but you didn't--
if you queried the
system from somewhere
else, or a different point
in time, or whatever.
There is no such thing
as eventually getting
the information.
You either have the
information or you don't.
And you have it together
or you don't have it.
You have it all
together or you don't.
And this is kind of what
traditional databases offer
as strong consistency.
That's what ACID transactions
actually mean, as you know,
Atomicity, Consistency,
Isolation, and Durability.
And there is this consistency.
MARK MANDEL: So I
want to bring up
the magic elephant in the room.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The magic elephant.
MARK MANDEL: The magic elephant.
So we've talked a little bit
about CAP theorem, right?
So consistency, availability
partition tolerance.
Does that mean,
like, we beat it?
Or like--
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: You
mean beat the CAP theorem?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, did
we beat it, as like,
we defied laws of physics?
Like what are we doing here?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So
we certainly did not
defy the laws of physics.
Let's put that out there.
So the question is, does
Spanner break CAP theorem?
Not really.
What Spanner does
is it always chooses
consistency over availability.
So it always chooses C over
A in face of partitions.
So CAP theorem is consistency,
availability, and partitions,
and how do you-- or network
partitions to be specific--
and how does a
system handle that.
Do you choose C or A in
the face of partitions
is the very basic answer.
And what we say is that Spanner
always opts for consistency,
hence we are a strongly
consistent system.
However, because we can leverage
Google's networking and network
stack, which are
highly optimized,
and because we've built Spanner
to be a highly optimal system
when it comes to
these things, we
can actually get very high
availability and performance
as well.
So Spanner offers up to
five nines of availability.
And we can be this strongly,
or highly available,
even in the face of partitions
because of the optimized Google
network and our own
optimized stack.
So I would recommend that
anybody who's really interested
go look at Eric Brewer's
paper on this exact topic.
It's called "Spanner
and the CAP theorem."
We linked to it
from our website,
which is
cloud.google.com/spanner.
It's a full research paper
written by the person who
wrote the CAP theorem.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: He has more--
that paper has more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think he
knows what the CAP theorem is.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
He can get into that
in much more detail.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well, so you
mentioned a little bit before,
basically where you
said there's a SQL
query, a language
that you could use
for querying, so
basically listing data
and aggregating and
stepping through it.
So if I'm a developer, how
do I go in and alter it,
or add data to it?
What does that
interaction look like?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So first of
all, we have DDL statements.
So if you want to
change your schema,
you use general DDL
statements, like Alter Table,
Drop Table, Add
Column, whatever.
The interesting
thing about Spanner
is that all the
schema changes happen
online, which means you
don't have to bring down
your database in order for the
database to reconfigure itself,
where we lay out the data
for these things, which
is super cool.
Also if you want to alter
data, Read, Write, Edit,
do CRUD operations,
then we actually
have to go through the
programmatic API to do that.
We don't offer Insert, Update,
Delete in SQL currently.
We have plans to
provide that later.
But currently we
don't have that.
So you have to use
a programmatic API.
However, we've tried to
make that API as close
to SQL as possible.
So you do do inserts, like the
Key Words, or Insert, Update,
or Delete.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, cool.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And
we have a mutation API
so you can put all these
different statements together
into mutations.
For reads, you can
use the read API.
If you're familiar with read
APIs from NoSQL systems,
it's a much easier transition.
And you can also use SQL.
So you can do Select,
Star from Table,
where x equal to
foo or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the API you mentioned,
not the SQL API but the other
one, is that based on gRPC?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
So we offer the client
libraries in what
we call all silver languages,
but right now we're
offering them in Java,
Go, Python, and Node.js.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And
we'll have PHP, and Ruby,
and C-sharp later in the year.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And we
expect that most customers--
because these are the most
popular languages that we know
of and we've seen requests for--
most customers should
be able to just use
these client libraries
instead of having
to code against the REST
API or the gRPC API.
We also have a
JDBC driver that's
a read-only JDBC
driver, for those
who are interested
in that or are more
familiar with those semantics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So let's talk about if
I'm a developer-- well,
I am a developer.
MARK MANDEL: You
are a developer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If I was
to create a new project,
why would I use Spanner?
Like in what use cases
are you saying, like,
oh, yeah you should go
with Spanner, rather
than, I don't know,
like Cloud SQL, or maybe
Datastore or Bigtable?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
That's a very common
question, actually.
And I think once you
look at what you're
trying to accomplish with
your data storage system,
then it becomes much easier.
So as I said, Spanner
is scale out relational.
So if you have a
relational data,
and you really like MySQL,
or all your data is in MySQL,
and it fits in your
MySQL instance,
or Cloud SQL instance,
then you should just
use Cloud SQL to
manage MySQL Service.
However, if you're running out
of the capacity for that MySQL
or Cloud SQL instance, because
you have way too much data
or way too much workload
that cannot be handled by one
vertical solution, then
Spanner is a great alternative.
Because if you're running into
the seams of your MySQL box,
then you have two alternatives--
either to go to a sharded MySQL
solution, which has a whole set
of issues that you have to deal
with managing and
maintaining that,
or you then have to
transition to NoSQL,
which you give up
all those cool--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Goodbye transactions.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Correct.
So in that case, you don't
have to make that trade-off.
You go to Spanner, basically.
In terms of when
to use Datastore,
or Bigtable, and Spanner--
as I said, Bigtable
is a key value store.
It's a wide column store.
It doesn't have SQL, or
strongly typed schemas,
or multi-row transactions,
and things like that.
But it's great for sort of
large-scale data analytics
and things like that.
So you can totally see that.
Also it's not
synchronously replicated.
So Spanner, by default, out
of the box is synchronously
replicated, which means
when you write to Spanner,
you're actually writing to
n different replicas, which
are, in our regional
configuration,
has three replicas, whereas--
and they're not
eventually consistent.
They're strong.
It's synchronously replicated
without compromising
our performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
And then Datastore
is an object store, essentially,
or a document store.
So again, it doesn't have
the same relational semantics
that Spanner or MySQL have.
So again, if you don't
need relational semantics,
or if you just want to--
it's a great product to
get started on as well.
Like if you have low QPS
or low-query numbers,
and you just want to get started
and use a consistent data
store, which is, again,
multi-region and available,
highly available, then I think
Datastore is a great option.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm really curious--
BigQuery.
I know a lot of people
who will take data
from maybe Datastore
or other places,
push it into BigQuery
so that they're
able to do large-scale
querying for analytics.
Sounds like Cloud Spanner will
handle that workload as well?
Where does the line
get drawn there?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So I think
this is the OLTP versus OLAP
conversation.
Because BigQuery is
ultimately a data
warehousing solution but in
the Cloud and with scalability.
So it's really meant
for running OLAP style.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is OLAP?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sorry.
Yeah, so OLTP stands for
Online Transaction Processing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And OLAP
stands for Online Analytics
Processing.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see, OK.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So you know,
the cool thing about BigQuery
is that you can actually
import data from different data
sources, and then combine them,
and then run analytics on them,
so do aggregations and
roll-ups and things.
You can sort of have as
much data as you need,
or as little data as you need.
And you can run a bunch
of queries on this.
Spanner is your
operational database.
BigQuery is not an
So Spanner is where you
put your production data.
That's where you run your
mission critical application.
And then if you want to combine
that data with other sources,
or if you want to run a
billing pipeline that's
monthly aggregations
or something like that,
then you transfer that
data into BigQuery.
Then you can join it
with other data sources
or just run long running
operations on it as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
we should do, definitely,
an episode on all the
different ways of storing data,
because we keep on adding more.
And we had one,
episode 14, I think.
It was like, storage
in the Cloud.
We should remake that
because there's so
many cool things going on.
So there's so many other
topics that I'd like to cover.
Like, there's through
time, and super cool stuff
with like atomic
clocks and stuff.
But I don't think we're
going to have the time
to cover all of those.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could
you share some good place,
like Talk or Document, where
could I start learning more
about these things?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: It depends
on what you want to learn.
Are you talking about Spanner?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How about Spanner--
like the magic sauce behind it.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, so of course
there is a canonical
2012 OSDI research paper
that you can see on
research.google.com.
That's a great starting
place to understand
where Spanner came from.
But in terms of Spanner
right now, and Cloud Spanner,
this service specifically,
I would recommend going
to our technical
documentation page,
which is
cloud.google.com/spanner/docs.
We actually have a
white paper section
there where we kind
of basically talk
about the technical details
of some parts of our system
that we've learned are
very exciting to a lot
of our developers.
And we kind of try to open
the hood a little bit so
that people can
understand, well,
how do reads and writes work?
And how do queries work?
And how do you optimize queries?
And how do you have efficient
schemas, things like that.
So I would recommend that
white paper section as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And is there,
by any chance, any sessions
going on at Cloud Next?
Is anyone at Cloud Next
going to talk about Spanner?
I'm gonna see if they are.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Actually
we have at least two sessions
on Cloud Spanner.
There is the Spanner 101,
or sorry, Cloud Spanner
101 and Cloud Spanner 201.
So I would recommend
people who are
going to Next to attend
those if they want
to learn more about Spanner.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, I
think as the name suggests,
one of them is more
of a broad overview,
and the second one
is more in depth.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And they're
all going to be recorded.
So if you cannot
attend, don't worry.
We've got you covered.
We release that later on.
I don't know exactly
the dates but soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I'm also wondering,
do you know publicly
about anyone who's using
Cloud Spanner now in the wild?
What are they doing with it?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so
actually as I said earlier,
we ran an Early
Access Program that
generated tremendous interest.
And many companies signed
up for that to try it out
and to give us feedback, which
is where we took the time
to then generate, or create
the Cloud Spanner product.
Two of them are actually
mentioned in our blog post that
we had for the Cloud Spanner
release and on our product
page, which is
cloud.google.com/spanner,
which is Quizlet and JDA.
Quizlet actually did
a deep dive analysis,
because they have a
sharded MySQL solution.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: And yeah,
they had all sorts of problems
with it.
So they were looking for
the next generation thing
that they could go
to and hopefully
forget about all the
headaches that they
had with the sharded solution.
So they have a pretty
in-depth technical blog
that they wrote that is, again,
linked from our product page
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we'll have links
to that in the show notes.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Great.
Yeah, so I think those two
are definitely exciting.
Now that we are
a public product,
we expect more and more
customers to sign up
and obviously use this for their
mission control and production
workloads.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
curious as well,
was there any big surprises,
as well, when people
started playing with Spanner?
Like, I never thought anyone
would do that with it,
or something
interesting like that?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Because we'd
been running Spanner service
internally, we'd kind
of come across most
of those kind of questions.
I will say the level to which
people were excited about SQL--
I'll summarize it a little bit.
Internally at Google,
as you were saying,
people are very excited
about the NoSQL API,
or used to be anyway.
Now we have over 2,000
customers using Spanner.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
But it's interesting
when we did hack days with
some of our customers,
which was very exciting to us.
And everybody that looked
at SQL, they were like,
no, you can't do this, can you?
And then--
MARK MANDEL: We were
like, yes we can.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so
we decided to actually keep--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Select,
Star, across the world.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, pretty
much, and we capped the SQL API
and have decided
to grow it as well.
So that's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you mentioned that you
were thinking about growing it.
What are the kind of
things we might expect
from Cloud Spanner going on?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah,
in terms of road map,
I think we obviously
are planning
to become generally
available towards the middle
of this year.
We have a multi-region solution
coming out right after.
And then the general
idea with Spanner is to,
or the general plan,
is to integrate
with other GCP services, such
as Data Flow, BigQuery, Pub/Sub.
All those kinds of
things so that GCP
can be your one-stop data
shop, where you can use Spanner
for your production
workload, but also
have messages using Pub/Sub
that can automatically happen.
And you can automatically
transition your data
into BigQuery for
those federated queries
and things like that.
So I think we have an
interesting year-plus ahead.
MARK MANDEL: So where is
Spanner specifically targeted?
Like, size of company, pricing,
where does that position itself
in terms of the
audience that would
be participating and using it?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
So Spanner actually--
it doesn't really matter
which size company you are.
Really, it's about what features
do you look for and does
Spanner have them or not?
So it could be for SMEs or
it could be for enterprises.
I can tell you that from
a feature point of view,
we definitely have--
we're enterprise ready
with the features.
Like we have IAM, which is
Identity and Access Management,
in the beta product already.
We have audit logging.
We have encryption at rest by
default. We have a JDBC driver.
As I said, we had SQL, which
is ANSI C 2011 compliant.
And we have client libraries.
So we are definitely
enterprise ready.
But I think any size
company can sort of
take advantage of these
features without extra effort.
So it kind of comes free as part
of the system, out of the box.
And so even if you're a
startup or a small company,
but your data is your
prized possession,
it's your business intelligence
or your business strong point,
then you can start with Spanner.
And then you don't have
to worry about ever
having to deal with Scale,
or managing that database,
or provisioning for
disaster recovery
by replicating it into
multiple availability zones.
All of those things come
built in and by default.
So it has a lot more
than just scalable
relational database to offer.
And as I said, it
has high visibility.
It has high performance.
It can grow and grow
as your data grows.
And you don't have
to worry about it.
You focus on your
business and growing it.
And we take care of the rest.
MARK MANDEL: So if I'm
like a four-person team
but I want to build
the next PokemonGo,
I should be looking
towards something like this
rather than just putting
MySQL in my own box somewhere.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
I mean, I would
say if you're looking at putting
your MySQL on your own box,
sure, but then you don't get all
the availability and management
for out of the box.
MARK MANDEL: But
yeah, I know I'm
going to get this huge
pipeline of traffic,
then I need to
build accordingly.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
I would say the
other aspect here,
which I've heard a lot about
over the last couple of days
since we've
launched, is pricing.
There has been a lot of
sort of consternation
and whether it's really
priced for smaller companies.
And I would say we put a lot
of thought in our pricing.
And I think we are very
competitively priced
for the value that
Cloud Spanner offers.
If you really look across
the Cloud data storage
offerings with
competitors and stuff,
I think we are
pretty well-priced.
You know, you're getting a fully
managed, very high availability
service.
So imagine you not
having to get out
of bed in the
middle of the night
because your database
machine crashed,
or because it's running
out of memory so you
have to provision more memory.
Just to talk about pricing a
little bit really quickly--
so when you buy a
node, you actually
get three replicas of the node.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: We have three
different availability zones.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was going to ask you
that because that is not the
case for Bigtable for instance.
In Bigtable you need to create
a cluster with three nodes.
Here one node is enough.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
One node is enough.
It's the lowest.
We do recommend that
you create or get
three nodes just for production
grade availability and traffic.
But really you can buy one node.
But the point is that
one node gives you
three replicas, like
three nodes and three
different availability zones,
all of which are live nodes.
They can all serve data.
And they're not
just sitting there
as a master slave
kind of configuration,
because as I said
earlier, Spanner
is synchronously replicated.
So there is no-- it's all
sort of what would be called
master-master replication.
You get fully managed,
high availability.
You get SQL.
You get the scalability.
And you get these regional and
multi-region configurations
when they launch.
So there's a lot
there that you're
getting out of
Spanner for the price
that we're offering it for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, I
think it's definitely worth
taking into account
the fact that you don't
need to take care of
like, what happens
if your database disappears?
Because I don't know,
we've heard about stories
of these things happen.
And the fact that you don't
even need to care about it
at all, that is, I don't know,
if I was running a company,
I'd definitely consider it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
It's a trade off between
how much time do you
and your developers
and your IT staff
spend managing your database
versus building applications
and growing your business, and
what the trade off looks like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
the way to put it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well, I
think we are running out
of time a little
bit, but I'll ask
is there anything
we haven't covered,
or something you want to plug,
or promote, or announce that we
haven't managed to cover
in the half an hour
we've been running so far?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
There's so much more
that you can learn about
Cloud Spanner and Spanner.
There is definitely a
layered chocolate cake here,
and you can sort of keep
unlayering it, or unpeeling it.
There is a plethora of
information on our sites page
and, as I mentioned,
the White Papers.
So I would definitely sort
of go there and check it out,
and see if you can't find
what you're looking for there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'll
actually plug something here.
There is a very good talk
that is from Papers We
Love, which is a talk about
the Spanner paper given
by an ex-Googler engineer
that was working on the team.
And it's a pretty amazing talk.
So I'll try to put that
in the show notes, too.
I guess it's a good place
to start if you're not
into reading papers.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure,
yeah, and of course,
once the GCP Next
talks happen, they
will also be sort of reported.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
I'm very excited about those.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, Deepti, thank you
so much for joining us today.
Actually, that was an
amazing learning experience.
I learned way more about
Spanner than I knew previously.
And I'm very excited about it.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: I'm glad.
I'm glad to be here.
Thank you for having me.
And I hope this is useful
to all your listeners.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm sure.
It was helpful for me
at least, so I hope
it will be helpful for them.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Cloud Spanner
for everyone in the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
Thank you so much.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so
much to Deepti for joining us
for a fascinating interview.
I still can't decide if Spanner
is entirely magical unicorns,
but it is pretty amazing
in terms of what it does.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is definitely
powered by magical unicorns.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool, so why don't we go to
the question of the week,
sent to us by the
amazing Jessie Frazelle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So as part of her,
basically, let's
call it integration
into Google, she
decided to basically
move all her stuff
to Google Cloud Platform.
And she came up with
this little problem.
She wanted to run an SMTP
server, so a mail server,
on Google Cloud Platform.
And turns out that
it doesn't work.
So she asked me, how
is this and why not?
And it is in the
Docs, but I think
that it is something that
could be a little bit
surprising, so I guess
it's worth discussing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So it is definitely
worth noting,
Google Compute
Engine specifically
doesn't allow
outbound connections
on 25, 465, and 487, basically
because Spam, and abuse,
and bad things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Basically, there's this
thing called IP reputation.
So if you're sending
emails, the IP where
the email is coming
from, IP forward,
is actually very important.
So if we allowed everyone
to send emails from there,
the IPs would probably lose
their reputation quite fast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So it's something
we don't really want
to do because it
would be bad for our customers.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And also because it
would be a very easy way
to generate lots of Spam,
and Spam is not good.
So then we have
these limitations.
But we can work around
it quite easily.
You can use some services
that are already available.
And we have documentation
of how to use them.
So you can use Sendgrid,
Mailgun, or Mailjet.
Those are the ones we
have for recommendation.
And I think you use one of them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So they all come
with free tiers.
I use Sendgrid, personally.
So Sendgrid comes
with a free trial
of up to 12,000 transactional
emails free each month.
My blog does not send out
anywhere near that many emails,
so it works really, really well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Even though
you send it to all of your fans?
MARK MANDEL: All of
my fans, like my mom,
and a couple of cousins.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He has
a big family, 12,000.
Cool.
And then there's
also another option,
which is you can send
email through Google.
We have an SMTP relay service.
And basically what you do is
you send it through Google Apps,
even though the
email is not Gmail.
So there's these
little servers that
allows you to send it from
your server but through Google.
And all documentation will be
linked from the show notes.
So if this is something
that you want to do,
go read the documentation.
And of course, remember
that even though you
might use these
services, you still
need to add firewalls to make
sure that the traffic actually
goes through, as we
discussed in the networking
episode we had a long time ago.
You can go find them.
And they're very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well, that
sounds like that kind
of solves that problem.
What are you up to, Francesc?
What are you getting up to?
I know we're leading
up to Next, which
is kind of hectic
and crazy, but you
got anything else in the cards?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time this episode comes out,
I will be in India, in
GopherCon in India, in Pune.
Pune, which is how you
pronounce it, by the way.
MARK MANDEL: You know now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, now I know.
After that, I'll stay a
couple of days in Mumbai.
And then I'll come
back for Cloud Next.
And then after that,
I'll be getting
ready to go to GopherCon
in China, in Shanghai.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: So when this
comes out, the week after that
will be Game
Developer Conference.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
I heard about that.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is terrifying,
because lots to do there.
Yeah, I will be around.
If anyone wants to meet up,
feel free to ping me directly
on Twitter @neurotic.
I'm definitely going to be
floating around the booth
and a variety of events
we're sponsoring,
and our sponsored talk, and
all sorts of other fun stuff.
And then, yeah, you and I
are heading off to Next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And actually you were
mentioning that if someone's
coming to GDC, they
should let you know.
If anyone is coming to
Cloud Next, let us know.
We will have t-shirts.
MARK MANDEL: We
will have t-shirts.
We will have a
booth space set up.
We'll be doing recordings
again like we did last year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we'd love to meet you.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So come say hi.
We always appreciate that.
Well, Mark, thanks again for
such an interesting episode
today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
Francesc, thank you
for joining me once again.
And thanks to everyone
for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Talk
to you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]